kaleila and i have been watching alone
do you see the light list season
so if you guys don't know you have to
watch the show alone it's such a good
show
and you know it's 10 survivalists they
go out in the arctic
and they survive and in this season
i don't want to get any spoilers but i
guess there is a spoiler here
is the last two contestants is a man and
a woman
can i say that yeah yeah and the woman
there's 11 okay so you you have to last
100 days
and if you last 100 days in the arctic
you get
a million dollars okay
this girl this girl is 11 days in
no she's 89 days 89 is she has 11 days
left that's a very difficult
and she's like in the cameras like i
think i'm gonna make it but her her
her tone and her spirit
is like unlike you've ever seen it she's
a
[ __ ] winner genuinely the most
inspiring the way that she was just
gonna
that she was able to face those elements
and she had it
she [ __ ] cracked her head there's she
had a [ __ ]
porcupine spine needles embedded on her
shoulder there's so many things that
didn't go her way at all but there was
never a moment
in the entire 10 episodes where she
wasn't
joyful showing gratitude being positive
like i was in
awe like my jaws were on the floor like
how is she
how is she able to do this
so yeah and on the tip of her one of her
toes
there's some frostbite oh man
what dude doesn't that get turned into
basically dead yeah then gangrenous
yeah yeah yeah sure okay i'm not a
medical man
but i'm pretty sure that you're right
okay but it's at the tip of the toe
okay and she's like oh wow weird
i got frosted by the tip of my tongue
right the [ __ ]
show comes in right when she has 11 days
left we got to take you out
and she's like you know what yeah that
frostbite
you're gonna lose your foot don't you
think that that should be her decision
no i think it was her decision
ultimately no
it wasn't her it was because i read her
post her most recent post
what's a million dollars to a
survivalist with no feet
a toe no it would have spread 11 days
it is not a toe no way let's have this
debate i if you're going to tell me
right now
if you're going to tell me right now
lyla we're going to amputate your big
toe
or even half of my big toe and pay you a
million dollars i'd be like [ __ ] no
for me my toe is [ __ ] anyway with the
fungi
take three they're helping you take
three for a million dollars
who gives a [ __ ] yeah but okay imagine
this bobby you sit at home your
lifestyle
allows you to take three steps a day
like that's what you want to do right is
take three steps a day i'm somebody who
likes to hike and swim and do all that
no [ __ ] that
i want all of my you can walk without
toes
i don't want to live a life without feet
if it means
for a [ __ ] million dollars that's
fine but if they were if they would have
said this
on the show if they would have said
listen you might lose your toe
right we would like to take you out but
it's your decision
they never prompted that for her no they
were like we're taking you out she's
like really
she said that really agreed no
they they were taking her out no babe i
think you read it
differently than me no i yeah there's
only one way to read it
is they said we're taking you out and
she's like really
like yeah she's like but uh i feel great
i mean great spirits
they're like yep your toe we need to if
only we could get her on the show
then we could probably well i already
asked her on her [ __ ]
instagram and then other tiger belly
fans were like you should do it but she
didn't respond so it's fine
her name is callie russell yeah callie
russell [ __ ] she's
a badass really inspirational and um
she really um and the other girl too
kylan
oh my god because it was two two women
and a man at the end
yeah and the other girl kailyn oh my god
she's women are
[ __ ] tough man yeah
you know i i it's like because in that
episode
in that season you had real marine
you know like heavy duty like a sniper
i'm a sniper for like
special ops yeah like real tough guys
three weeks in they're done right you're
talking about
70 80 90 days in women are like
[ __ ] it i'm i'm in it i'm i'm
yeah and all the these tough guys are
dropping out
these women are [ __ ] strong man i
think like psychologically they're
always the most positive ones too
yeah in that show they're always the
ones who are a little bit more
light-hearted except for jordan because
jordan was
the greatest from beginning to end you
saw that jordan's the best oh i love him
so much yours is incredible but anyway
callie um
i know you know i you know i i reach out
to a lot of people on instagram
you know most people like who uh zac
braf
no response no [ __ ] response
um i've asked um um
was the english singer louis
that's why he won't because he knows
that you can't even say his name right
so why would he come on the show
i just i get brain dead there we go i'll
run into people i've known for 30 years
and forget their name
yeah that's who i am and that's what i
do
so you know george was playing a war
zone
you just uh angered klyla george why
would you do that i don't think you did
i don't think we did why are people why
why now george
do you feel like um excluded from the
fraternity